bienvenue dans cette nouvelle vidéo
alors aujourd'hui j'aimerais initiés
quelque chose d'un peu nouveau sur cette
chaîne vous savez sans doute que la
chaîne atteint dix mille abonnés donc ça
merci à tout le monde mais j'avais envie
un peu que celles-ci évoluent nous
inquiétez pas on va toujours retrouver
sur la chaîne des vidéos assez aboutie
qui traitent des concepts des auteurs
mais aussi
parfois de méthodologie consacrer tous a
consacré aux sciences sociales
mais j'avais envie aussi que sur la
chaîne ou retrouve vraiment des
recherches plus actuelles d'ailleurs
j'ai fait un petit sondage via l'onglet
communauté et plus de 95% des gens qui
suivent la chaîne ou qui pourraient être
intéressés par la chaîne trouve que ça
pourrait être une bonne idée donc l'idée
ce serait vraiment faire des résumés en
tout cas des présentations de recherche
qu'on peut trouver sur le net et qui ont
été réalisés récemment sur des sujets
contemporains souvent c'est vrai que par
exemple sur la vidéo de bourdieu et
toujours des commentaires qui arrive
qu'ils disent oui mais ça c'était
valable à l'époque de brou dit
aujourd'hui ça a beaucoup changé et je
réponds toujours la même chose dit oui
mais mon but ici c'est de présenter la
théorie de bon dieu tel qu'il a
formulées par exemple c'est pas de faire
une analyse de la théorie comment elle
va évoluer quarante ans après donc ça
c'est mon avis et complémentaires etc ce
qui se fait déjà et vraiment pour aller
au bout de ma pensée si vous voulez
j'aimerais que ça soit fait en direct un
de fer liu tube direct pour qu'il puisse
y avoir des échanges directement je
trouve que c'est ce qui manque un peu
sur cette chaîne c'est l'interactivité
est vraiment une co-construction
finalement
des contenus des vidéos et donc c'est
pour ça que ici aujourd'hui ben je vais
faire ça mais dans les conditions du
direct donc là je me suis installé comme
si je devais streamé
mais seulement je vais faire quand même
un montage parce que comme c'est la
première fois il ya peut-être des
problèmes techniques qui vont se poser
et à peut-être
des bleus je ne saurais pas quoi dire
donc je préfère vraiment faire un pilote
comme ça la première fois et si ça vous
intéresse qu il y ait des directs avait
dit le dites le parce que sur cette
chaîne bon c'est beaucoup de personnes
guéries sur cette chaîne finalement font
des recherches via youtube
un concept par un auteur ils ne
reviennent pas forcément sur sur la
chaîne pour voir d'autres contenus donc
ici comme c'est un peu plus particulier
s'il ya des personnes intéressés oui au
direct maman si c'est pour qu'il y ait
deux personnes qu'ils soient là quand il
ya des directs je ferai pas de direct
peu le format actuel ce que j'ai fait
aujourd'hui donc voilà ça c'est un peu
l'idée alors on va passer tout de suite
vous avez sans doute vu dans le rire
dans le titre de la vidéo qu'elle elle
qu'elle allait être le sujet mais en
fait voilà ce que ce que j'aimerais
aujourd'hui présentée c'est le travail
de thibaut mélodies qui est ou qui est
vraiment un jeune chercheur ou
contemporains et c'est ça qui
m'intéresse et j'avais vu finalement son
enquête passé sur kairn 1 c'est vraiment
dans les actualités du de cairns que
j'avais vu ça alors si vous savez pas
c'est quoi kern en fait en gros kern
c'est un gros un gros portails qui va
rassembler différents éditeurs de revues
scientifiques et donc sur kairn vous
allez retrouver beaucoup de publications
scientifiques alors pas tout parce qu'il
ya différents portails mais disons
conscience sociale c'est un des plus
intéressants et des plus riches
thibault besozzi en fait il est il est
docteur en sociologie et en démographie
je ne sais pas à qui s'adresse cette
vidéo vraiment faim en tout cas qui est
qui la regardent donc on va vraiment
aller au fond des choses bon bah un
docteur en sociologie c'est quelqu'un
qui a fait des études supérieures qui a
fait un master mais après ils se
dirigent vers l'enseignement
universitaire et la recherche est donc
là il passe le stade de docteur quoi
donc c'est un master plus trois ans vous
faites une thèse et vous obtenez le
titre de docteur donc voilà ça c'est du
high level en sciences sociales à titre
de comparaison moi je suis que je n'ai
qu'un master en sciences politiques
je veux dire par rapport à thibaut
bezoti ben voilà c'est un niveau au
dessus et donc il est chercheur
actuellement envoyés dans un laboratoire
interdisciplinaire qui s'appelle le
le laboratoire société sensibilité soins
il s'intéresse principalement
marginalité urbaine le monde un peu des
sans abri c'est ce qu'on va aborder
aujourd'hui et à l'espace public urbain
elle se fait un petit peu et qu un
sociologie de l'école de chicago
qui a vraiment étudié sont les premiers
qui ont étudié au 20e siècle vraiment
les interactions qui pouvait y avoir
entre les individus les groupes humains
et tout l'urbanité finalement et tout le
décorum urbain
donc ça c'est un petit peu pour pour le
présenter et au niveau de sa
de la recherche qui nous occupe ici on
va avoir directement un résumé qui est
proposée sur le site du kern c'est ça
qui est intéressant c'est quand vous
intéressez un objet en sciences sociales
et bien les études contemporaines et les
plus anciennes propose toujours un
résumé souvent les élèves ils aiment
bien les résumés quand ils doivent lire
un livre en français est bien ici en
sciences sociales c'est encore plus
simple puisque le résumé c'est vraiment
quelque chose d'officiel et
d'obligatoire entre guillemets on va le
dire ensemble parce que c'est ce qui
nous permet de comprendre vraiment tout
l'article et parfois je dis aux élèves
rien qu'avec l'abstract un l'abstract
c'est l'autre nom du résumé un cake
l'abstract à bien vous êtes en mesure
déjà d'avoir des éléments et donc on
gagne beaucoup de temps pour savoir si
l'article est intéressant ou pas en tout
cas dans le cadre de sa recherche ici on
fait un petit peu gratuitement
si vous êtes une en cours de recherche
c'est beaucoup plus intéressant encore
que fait donc en partant de l'étude de
la vie quotidienne des sans abri
rencontré à nancy
agglomération du grand est un recensant
trois cent mille habitants dont lé cadre
d'une recherche en immersion de nos
graphiques pendant huit mois si vous ne
savez pas c'est quoi l'immersion
ethnographique c'est un petit peu comme
les grands anthropologues ouvert au 20e
siècle claude lévi strauss qui allaient
s'immerger dans des tribus par exemple
en amazonie est bien ici le tibet aux
oiseaux dit lui a intégré vraiment le
monde des sans abri pendant huit mois
dans l'article il va pas dire exactement
les modalités après il ya d'autres
d'autres documents sur le net
auquel il ya un petit peu plus
prolifiques par rapport aux en tout cas
il en dit un peu plus là dessus et qui
nous permet de savoir comment ça s'est
passé si ça vous intéresse cet article
entend montrer les structures sociales
qui ordonne le monde des sans abri loin
des notions d'errance et de
désocialisation souvent mobilisés pour
caractériser la situation habituelle des
sans abri notre propos invite au
contraire à se focaliser sur la
dimension collective de l'expérience de
la rue et met ainsi en lumière les
structures spatio-temporelle relationnel
et morale on a déjà une structure ça
c'est vraiment trop attendre de sa
recherche
qui caractérise cette expérience on peut
dès lors appréhendé les sans abri comme
appartenant un véritable monde social
relativement structuré et observer
comment cet ordre social survit malgré
le turn-over dément du microcosme des
sans abri alors moi j'aime bien cette
cette étude or je les lui une première
fois pour préparer un petit peu cette
vidéo je laime bien pour plusieurs
raisons la première c'est que c'est très
clair au niveau de problématiques
souvent les élèves ont beaucoup de mains
la cible et les problématiques et
surtout des problématiques pertinentes
alors je rappelle qu'une problématiques
pertinentes c'est par exemple quelque
chose dans lesquels vous allez avoir
par exemple un axe de tension ou alors
une lacunes dans les connaissances ou
alors un paradoxe ça c'est vraiment des
des problématiques intéressante ici ce
qui est intéressant vous avez un double
problématique de première c'est que l'on
va déconstruire des représentations
sociales qu'on a du monde des sans abri
et d'ailleurs si vous allez sur la
société que vous allez voir il ya une
vidéo qui marche assez bien sur
l'exclusion sociale et jeudi dans ceux
ci je me souviens vaguement freiner
vidéo l'exclusion sociale c'est la
rupture des liens sociaux finalement
progressive et bien finalement l'article
2 et 6 2 thibault b2dix vient contredire
sa part l'observation empirique mais on
se rend compte qu'ils sont pas du tout
désocialisés donc ça c'est un premier
temps qui est très intéressant dans sa
recherche c'est qu'on va déconstruire
des représentations qu'on avait parfois
des gens qui gravitent dans le monde des
sciences sociales par exemple et
peut-être des chercheurs aussi voulu
revoir c'est très intéressant la
deuxième chose et que on a donc une
structure sociale qui existe quelque
chose d'organisé qui existe et dans le
monde des sceaux a pris il ya un turn
over comme le dit l'auteur il ya donc un
changement régulier des mots c'est pas
toujours les mêmes personnes parce que
des gens car il ya des gens qui meurent
il ya des gens qui qui partent de la rue
et on a quand même cette structure qui
se maintient donc ses deuxième
problématique dans la première qui est
intéressante aussi parce que là on a une
contradiction comment ça se fait que
comment ça se fait que ça se mette que
ça se maintient alors qu' il ya un
turnover des mondes alors j comment ça
se fait que parce que dans une vidéo de
bourdieu qu'est ce que j'avais mis sur
la chaîne d'ailleurs je pense bon dieu
dit voilà une bonne question de sciences
sociales ou les sciences sociales ça
répond à la question comment ça se fait
que commence à fait que si comment ça se
fait que ça et donc là voilà on est en
plein dedans moi je trouve ça déjà très
intéressant comme recherche de ce point
de vue là et puis vous allez voir dans
le dans l'article à ce cas très
intéressant c'est qu'il est très
scolaire je ne dis pas de manière
péjorative
c'est à dire qu'il ya beaucoup d'auteurs
qui sont mobilisés avec des concepts de
base qui sont mobilisés mais ça c'est de
la matière que je joue à mon sac et mon
sixième sur social en belgique si vous
êtes en france saf et terminale ou
première donc c'est super intéressant
parce que cet article là il permet
vraiment de rentrer dans le vif du sujet
à mon sens il n'est pas trop complexe et
un élève de 5e ou 6e bien sûr un élève
qui fédère d'étudiants pardon qui fait
des études supérieures au centre social
lui ça va être à son niveau mais c'est
vraiment un article qui permet de
rentrer agréablement dans les sciences
sociales et puis c'est un sujet je pense
un objet qui intéresse beaucoup de jours
nous voilà voilà pourquoi j'ai choisi
cet article l'op ce premier exercice de
présentation d'une recherche j'espère
que j'ai pas été trop bien sûr sur
l'introduction on va entrer tout de
suite dans le vif du sujet allez c'est
parti on va dans l'article fenêtre de
travail je prends aussi mes marques avec
obs
alors voilà l'article où on en est donc
vous avez bat le rappel des dettes des
références bibliographiques directement
le lien
comme je le disais vous avez directement
l'abstract quelques mots clés mais ça va
déjà on peut découvrir alors comment on
va faire je vais pas tout lire parce que
voilà l'article fait 21 une page je
pense mais j'ai souligné des éléments
importants et donc on va suivre ensemble
la structure mais on sait déjà de par
l'abstract qu' il va y avoir trois temps
puisqu'il nous dit que le monde social
des sans abri va être structuré ici
les structures par des structures se
passe sur temporel relationnel et morale
donc ça va être trois trois parties du
travail qu'on m'a retrouvé et c'est un
peu le coeur du travail alors comment ça
se passe mais il introduit assez
rapidement n'y a pas de blabla mon avis
inutile au début et puis le champ de la
recherche sur le sans abrisme c'est ce
qu'on appelle
les lectures l'exploration via les
lectures et donc là on fait un petit peu
ce qu'on appelle aussi un état de l'art
vous faire un peu le point sur tout ce
qui a été déjà fait par rapport à la
recherche sur ce thème là
alors si je me souviens bien ce que nous
dit thibault c'est que gilles bovon
c'est pour pas dire tout le temps au
tibet obesity
mais est ce qu'on nous dit c'est 400
membres par exemple la recherche
s'intéresser surtout sur les causes
de l'exclusion sociale ou en tout cas du
sans abrisme et puis il va nous aussi
nous préciser
ici dans cette recherche on va
s'intéresser vraiment aux sans abri
proprement dit parce que dans le monde
de la rue on peut avoir des sdf sans
domicile fixe mais qui ont quand à
domicile en fait qu'ils vont passer
d'une structure à l'autre qui vont
passer d'une forme d'assistanat je le
dis comme ça peut-être un peu grossier
de le dire comme ça mais pour eux n 8
ans
à l'autre tandis que le sans abrisme
c'est vraiment des gens qui sont dans la
rue alors ça veut pas dire qu'ils vont
pas aller dormir dans une structure
d'hébergement mais c'est jamais que pour
une nuit et toute la journée il se
retrouve vraiment dans la rue donc ça
c'est vraiment ont 20 10 à 20% de la
population sdf qui est sans abri et lui
s'intéresse à ces embrasser sans abri la
kiss on a bien sûr annoncé
voilà c'est ce qu'on dit ici
et rien à redire alors il ya des
éléments g souligné qui me semblait très
intéressant il précise aussi que lui va
être plutôt dans un paradigme
interactionniste alors c'est quoi
l'interactionnisme koné goffman hong
kong becker ce sont certains courants
qui vont vraiment étudié les faits
sociaux de par les interactions en
considérant que ce sont d'abord les
interactions qui vont constituer en
quelque sorte le creuset dans lequel
tout le reste va se forger que les
individus vont acquérir une certaine
identité de par leurs interactions par
exemple
ici l'article vise donc à saisir les
dynamiques interactionnelle de
déconstruction reconstruction
identitaire des sans abri donc on va
s'intéresser aussi à leur identité et ça
c'est aussi un concept de base des
sciences sociales l'identité et
d'identité va être forgée par par ces
interactions mais surtout la formation
de groupes et de réseaux d'interactions
d'interconnaissance localisés ils rares
chizé est travaillée par des valeurs
plus ou moins partagé ici on a vraiment
tout son petit programme de recherche 1
où il va nous montrer un petit peu tout
les réseaux tous les réseaux et toutes
les interactions qui peuvent aller à
voir et surtout que tout ça est fait
selon certaines règles les règles ce
sont les valeurs qui sont plus ou moins
partagé et que finalement on est face à
un monde social à part entière je vous
mettrais de toute façon le lien vers
l'article je vous conseille de lire je
pourrais mettre aussi ma version ici
surlignés
en ligne comme ça vous pourrez avoir
accès à un petit peu au point
d'attention que j'avais moi même
souligné
et donc là on est vraiment sur la
construction jusque là sur la
construction de son objet quoi on est
vraiment sur les étapes et une deux
trois de la recherche et puis ici on va
passer à l'observation
comment va-t-il réaliser son observation
alors les élèves qui sont vraiment tu
subis coup vous y est mais on n'a même
pas formulé de modèle d' analyse on n'a
même pas formuler d'hypothèses comment
ça se fait en fait parce que son
hypothèse ll be site ici c'est que on
est face à un véritable monde social et
donc l'hypothèse pourrait être le monde
des sans abri est un monde social à part
entière ou un système social ou quelque
chose comme ça premier ici parle de
monde social
donc autant reprendre ça et comme on est
sur une démarche très inductive 1 il va
vraiment partira collecte d'informations
très qualitative mais il sait pas
exactement ce qu'ils cherchent il sait
en gros mais ça devrait être précisée
parce que c'est vraiment une approche
ethnographique et donc là on va partir
plus tôt de la réalité pour après
formuler une théorie mais ça veut pas
dire qu'il n'a pas des hypothèses
puisque en fait il part déjà avec ces
hypothèses
comme quoi il va trouver quelque chose
où il ya du lien social organisé
structuré
alors comment va-t-il faire une méthode
d'immersion être nos graphiques j'en ai
déjà un petit peu parlé dans l'ain
solution pour mener à bien ce projet
nous avons donc déployer une méthode
d'immersion ethnographique qui s'est
étalée sur une période de 8 mois pendant
huit mois il va vraiment intégrer le
monde des sans-abri entre septembre 2007
et avril 2018 nous avons passé plus de
300 heures dans la rue et dans les
services sociaux au contact direct des
sens en paix
alors après il explique il explique
aussi qui va aller sur des parkings
souterrains des squats des chambres de
foyers alors après il se veut surfer sur
youtube vous trouverez une décennie
interview où il explique que parfois
c'était assez chaud parce que lui il est
pas de ce monde là est donc au départ il
faut se faire accepter
une fois qu'on soit acceptée on est un
peu être invité à saint amand il ya les
des sans abri qui se drogue devant lui
donc ça le choc au départ ou alors ils
évitent d'aller avec certains individus
mais il le dit que en fait c'est des
représentations et c'est parce qu'ils se
méfient mais l'europe a dû se méfier
parce que en fait les gens sont très
sympas et donc vous pouvez imaginer tout
ce que cela induit comme ans comme
recherche doit être assez assez dingue
comme comme observation n'est pas tous
on mesure où je serais incapable de
faire ce genre d'observation
ce qui est très intéressant avec ce
genre de méthode c'est qui va pouvoir
vraiment rentrés l'intérieur comprendre
les logiques
s'il a fait une enquête les les gens ne
se seraient sans doute pas confier comme
il se confie actuellement donc je vais
changer une fois la vue soit plus sympa
vous aussi
donc
il va pouvoir ici confrontés les dires
veillir de dire de déclaration de
témoignages est aussi observer comment
les gens font est donc vraiment mettre
en relation les discours et les
pratiques est ce que les gens font ce
qu'ils disent et disent ce qu'ils font
donc c'est très intéressant parce qu'on
voit très très loin dans l'opinion
quelque part c'est pas juste faire
confiance à ce qu'on nous dit non il
peut le vérifier aussi
et donc ils le disent on va remettre en
question certaines certaines
représentations certaines idées reçues
alors on retrouve sa structure
organisation spatio-temporelle
structuration relationnel s'effectuera
ce moral on a déjà parlé dans l'abstract
donc ici on est vraiment dans le coeur
de l'arctique sur ce qu'ils formulent
comme comme nouvelles connaissances
envie de dire et on retrouve ici dans
les sous titres cette structure la doc
si on est en recherche
d'informations bien toilé directement si
on veut en savoir plus sur cette partie
là tout le reste c'est de la
méthodologie c'est la construction c'est
moins intéressant parce qu'on n'est pas
sur la du savoir de nouveaux savoirs
créés tandis qu'ici salle les uns c'est
vraiment le coeur de son article
alors on doit on doit faire l'hypothèse
non traitée ici et je le dis souvent aux
élèves une recherche de sciences
sociales c'est souvent plus de questions
à la fin que de réponses on aura sans
doute des réponses partielles mais
il y aura aussi des nouvelles questions
qui vont émerger et ici c'est ce que
nous dit
l'auteur
doit faire l'hypothèse non traitées que
le contexte urbain le nombre de sans
abri présents dans la ville sont des
facteurs déterminants de l'organisation
sociale la restructuration éventuelle de
tels maux sociaux donc ça veut dire
qu'on pourrait faire après une démarche
beaucoup plus déductive un peu plus à ce
sujet durkheim et j'ai envie de dire
comment nous on apprend au cours de
sciences sociales ses de formuler des
hypothèses est l'hypothèse la toute
faite le monde social à sa structuration
va dépendre de deux variables
indépendantes
la première le contexte urbain
peut-être l'urbanisme en tant que telle
la façon dont la ville est structuré
créé
matériel et ce matériel va définir des
structures sociales mais aussi le nombre
de sans abri présent et donc vous
pourrez vérifier par une observation
beaucoup plus direct moins
inclusive - nos graphiques
et la multiplier beaucoup plus les cas
d'observation quelque part pour vérifier
cette hypothèse là vous voyez il n'est
pas dit que l'auteur dans de prochaines
recherches ne vérifie pas cette
hypothèse
c'est ça qui est intéressant
alors sur l'organisme l'organisation
spatio temporelle du monde des sans abri
qu'est ce que ça veut dire mais ça veut
dire en fait que le temps et l'espace
vont être structuré pour les sans abri
c'est pas juste ils vont juste la zone
et tout ça c'est plus compliqué que ça
encore une fois et donc leur vie va être
rythmée par différents moments et par
différents endroits en commission le dis
pas par exemple la gare est un endroit
voilà très très important le haut c'est
là où on va parce que la guerre on peut
rentrer éventuellement pour se protéger
c'est un lieu de passage au qui vend
tellement ça peut être des ressources
via la manche qu'on peut faire pareil
pour la devanture d'un supermarché où le
parvis d'une église
donc ce sont des endroits qui sont super
important ils sont content dans sa
recherche que ces endroits là sont
connus sont connues par tous les gens
qui y vivent dans ce milieu là on a des
endroits qui sont plus valorisé que
d'autres et puis aussi les lieux au rap
dormir qui sont super important on pense
peut-être un pont un parking des choses
comme ça mais c'est aussi les centres
d'hébergement
ou les squats
la routinisation individuelles et
collectives du quotidien c'est ce qu'on
dit c'est que la journée va être triplés
autour de 17 différents endroits mais
aussi dans un certain dans une certaine
chronologie alors la journée il ya
d'abord trois choses à faire quand des
sans abri sur sa journée est d'abord un
objectif matériel gagner un peu d'argent
ici c'est le précise sauf à la manche
soit faire du trafic du vol
récupération je vois pas ça se voit
aussi tout un enjeu de restauration de
soi et du corps donc c'est à dire où est
ce qu'on va manger où est ce qu'on va se
laver laver ses vêtements éventuellement
dormir ça c'est les lieux de récupérer
de restauration époque où il le dit et
enfin le troisième enjeu c'est où est ce
qu'on va pouvoir avoir des contacts
parce que c'est ce qu'il montre c'est
que les sans abri recherche des contacts
avec les autres sans abri certains vont
être à part mais c'est pas la majorité
et donc sert toute la journée est
rythmée autour de ces trois de ces trois
tâches
alors il explique ben voilà l'amour dit
si tu essaies c'est une tâche qui permet
de produire
certains revenus il ya différents postes
il ya des postes ils sont plus
intéressants que d'autres parce que
c'est ce qu'il dit ici ils vont offrir
de l'argent mais aussi par exemple
sortie d'un supermarché les gens voient
aussi donné à manger pour donner aussi
peut-être à boire et donc ça peut être
intéressant parce qu'il ya
des postes qui marche mieux il y aura
aussi une plus value
dans le monde des sans abri la mange ou
des lâchers
ou est ce qu'il explique c'est que la
manche est aussi organisée par exemple
les bons endroits il va y avoir des
relais donc quelqu'un est un endroit par
exemple jusque 16h et puis après ils
guettent la place pour quelqu'un qui
connaît quoi on pas dire les amis parce
que c'est ce qu'ils disent dans le monde
des sans abri l'amitié c'est pas un
c'est pas une valeur ou de casser pas un
concept qui marche
enfin qui est pertinent mais voilà il ya
des relations de loyauté ou
on a des alliés comme ça donc on peut
garder la place pour un de ses amis par
exemple auquel toute une structure comme
ça qui se met en place
ce qui est paradoxal c'est que je les
dis hein les
sans abri sont
sont soumis à différentes temporalités
aux dents dans leurs journées vont faire
différentes choses et en fait qu'est-ce
qui qu'est ce qui va obliger qui est une
chose comme ça en fait ce sont les
horreurs par les horaires des centres
d'accueil ou alors il faut quitter le
centre avoir à cette heure est donc en
fait les sans abri vont aller au
rendez-vous qu'il souhait qui sont
fixées par les services sociaux et donc
ce qu'il dit ce qui est paradoxal c'est
que finalement le fait que des des
individus au la zone où erre dans la
ville finalement ce système qui veut ça
c'est système social qui est mis en
place qui le sac au dos c'est un peu
paradoxal quelques peurs
alors on passe au deuxième temps après
la structuration spatio-temporelle c'est
tout le réseau social
la structuration relationnel du monde
des sans-abri et c'est ce qui explique
ici il explique j'ai déjà dit qu'il y
avait des alliances et des conflits donc
à ce moment il ya des dd vraiment des
relations de loyauté avec du don et du
contre don fait confiance une fois et
puis ça permet de mettre en place une
relation et puis
exemple il ya quelque chose qui se passe
mal au niveau de la
du retour qu'on peut faire nous par
exemple vous avez donné de l'argent pour
dépanner quelqu'un est cette personne
elle a jamais eu rétrocéder une faveur
ou
de l'argent mais what you quelque chose
comme sa femme l'a pas rendu quelque
part ce que vous lui avez donné il va y
avoir un conflit et bien sûr on va plus
être dans une relation d'alliance quoi
donc c'est un peu et c'est un peu comme
ça d'ailleurs
ils se connaissent tous ça on y
reviendra dans le monde des sdf sont des
sans abri tout le monde se connaît en
tout cas dans une ville comme nancy est
une des personnes qu'il suit dans son
observation elle le dit ici c'est plus
belle la zone la plus belle la vie le
feuilleton un débat ici c'est plus belle
la zone tout le monde se connaît donc
c'est un peu un fin du tour dans lequel
il ya des retournements de situation il
ya des alliances il ya des choses comme
ça quoi
mais comme je le disais c'est rarement
des termes d'amitié
et puis parfois il ya des alliances qui
se font plus facilement en fonction de
l'origine ça ne le dis pas ici mais le
dit dans l'interview qui est sur youtube
par exemple par origine ethnique ou
géographique
les sans abri d'europe de l'est ont su
regrouper les sans abri issu de la gamme
vont se regrouper ensemble les jeunes
vont aussi avoir tendance à se regrouper
le psy par famille si vous êtes avec
votre frère dans la rue il y aura des
des regroupements et ce qu'il dit ici
c'est que à saint amand on va pas parler
d'amitié mais si on a vraiment des liens
très forts avec une autre personne on va
utiliser les termes relatifs à la
famille voilà c'est mon frère
donc l'amitié un peu zappé et
directement on arrive sur des liens
familiaux finalement ils sont
recompositions
familiales
des sans abri c'est ce qu'on disait au
début et de reconstruction identitaire
et ce sont des gens qui ont tout perdu
quasi tous qui n'ont presque plus rien
mais le monde des sans abri l'heureux
leur permet de retrouver certaines
choses de retrouver une certaine dignité
entre guillemets en tout cas pas pour
nous mais pour ce qu'ils sont monde des
sans abri on est forts près le retrouve
on retrouve ward baker avec hosiden nous
qui sommes outsiders on ne peut pas
comprendre le monde les insiders c'est
un peu ça une fois que tu es dedans il
ya des choses nouvelles qui vont se
passer pour toi donc c'est ça c'est ça
que ça veut dire quand il parle de
reconstruction identitaire et on
reconstruit des choses et c'est pour ça
aussi que d'essence de les personnes
sans abri ont du mal ne veulent pas
quitter ce monde là parce qu'ils ont
reconstruit on se reconstruit des choses
finalement alors ça peut nous apparaître
totalement futile ça peut nous
apparaître vraiment
comment dire très précaire mais voilà
quand à rien
presque rien c'est déjà quelque chose ça
veut dire
voilà il y a comme on le disait plein de
relations qui font qu'il ya radio
cendres abri quelque part c'est fou les
sans abri vous vont s'informer
mutuellement et parfois il ya des des
retenues d'information parce que
l'information est une ressource parfois
on donne l'information c'est une
ressource donc c'est un monde assez
complexe aussi quoi avec le nom des lois
spécifiques
alors il ya plein de choses qui se
passent il ya des dépendances il ya
aussi des dominations
alors voilà des réseaux
d'interconnaissance qui favorise la
possibilité de vendre d'acheter certains
produits moi ça me rappelle un petit peu
les films qu'on voit alors c'est
peut-être un peu caricatural mais sur le
monde de la prison qu'on voit un film
comme un prophète qui parle un peu de la
vie carcérale on voit que le réseau de
connaissances cd des ressources que tu
peux avoir en plus quoique c'est super
important c'est pas comme nous dans
notre monde dans lequel on vit au
magasin où la ressource et l'argent
finalement le fait de connaître des gens
c'est pas tout en déterminant saleh dans
certains milieux dans certaines
situations voilà tu vas acheter à manger
mais dans ce monde là c'est tout à fait
l'inversé
et donc la connaissance peut amener des
ressources supplémentaires
alors il ya des rapports de protection
par rapport si vous êtes une personne
âgée une femme des personnes handicapées
elles sont plus protégés
et c'est ce que je disais la protection
en tant que tel est une ressource qui
est considérée comme un don un plan
contre dont une sorte de féodalité comme
ça où situez protégé par quelqu'un tu
vas peut-être lui donner des
informations
on va peut-être lui donner de l'argent
ou tu vas peut-être nature lui donner
j'ai pas déçu sans se droguer ou de
prostituées si tu es une femme c'est un
homme et que ça intéresse le partenaire
est ce que nous dit ici l'auteur sait
que comme il ya des commérages ça prouve
bien qu'il ya tout un réseau
d'interconnaissance si si les gens
étaient totalement isolé c'est une
preuve de son hypothèse que c'est bien
un monde social si les gens étaient
isolés il n'y aurait pas des ragots il y
aurait pas d échanges d'informations
comme ça
il insiste vraiment vraiment là-dessus
jeu mais il va pas dire qu'il est sdf il
dit d'abord qu'il est écrivain écrivains
sociologues
et en fait ils tombent c'est ce qu'il
explique ici ils tombent après quelques
mois sur un inconnu quelqu'un qui
n'avait jamais vu et cette personne lui
dit ah c'est toi l'écrivain y en a pas
mal qui parle de toi en ce moment
j'attendais de tomber surtout c'est bien
la preuve c'est bien la preuve que le
cas du ragot et qui a des échanges si on
était dans un monde complètement explosé
où les individus sont atomisés dans le
sens où ils sont réduits alors seul
individualités et on va pas sûrs de
réflexion et alors il ya une fonction
sociale au niveau des ragots et au
niveau des commérages et tout ça c'est
que alors nous dans notre même façon que
les sans abri sont sont vus négativement
cette plus positivement mais ils sont
toujours vu comme comme des gens moins
bien à qui manque quelque chose si vous
voulez et bien dans le nombre des sans
abri a encore un processus distinction
qui jouent ils vont se distinguer entre
eux et donc les ragots sont l'occasion
de de faire vraiment jouer une sorte de
tusa au sens de bourdieu de jugement de
valeur finalement qu'on va porter sur
les autres pour finalement se distinguer
dire que soit on est mieux que l'autre
par exemple avec tel autre voilà c'est
vraiment un cas mais que le cndd alcoolo
qu'il ait aucune dignité que lui s'est
pas élevé son chien correctement et donc
les ragots sont l'occasion aussi de
mettre le doigt sur des pratiques qui
sont déjà condamnés dans le microcosme
mais en plus de dire si toi tu dis mais
lui il n'est pas capable de faire ça oui
où elle fait ça pas bien toi ça veut
dire que tu fais bien distincts ça c'est
dur
alors au niveau vraiment ici de la forme
du réseau d'interconnaissance on est ici
comment ça va se structurer derrière
d'abord parfois il ya des groupes de
trois quatre cinq plusieurs individus
alors les groupies sont pas stables dans
le temps et une action plus stable que
d'autres mais on peut avoir comme nous
l'a vu des alliances qui tombe qui
deviennent caduques et donc du coup le
groupe change et à quoi va servir le
groupe comment le groupe à gibles le
groupe par exemple il va occuper un
espace où il va organiser une certaine
façon d'avoir de revenus
donc c'est finalement
je veux dire travailler mais organiser
ensemble certaines activités du
quotidien c'est à ça que le groupe sert
par exemple ici ce qu'on explique voilà
pour trouver différentes ressources
partagées différentes ressources
l'argent la nourriture les boissons les
drogues des informations le groupe va
être quelque chose qui va permettre de
faire ça mieux et plus efficacement mais
on retrouve aussi des binômes
par exemple des groupes qui peut
imploser par exemple des binômes et il
ya des binômes avec des relations de
domination par exemple l'un va protéger
l'autre l'aude va ramener par exemple le
produit de la manche des échanges comme
ça et ici on a toute la structure
sociale du monde des sans abri tel que
l'a observé thibault des outils avec les
groupes ils trouvent ici les groupes
alors plus ils sont foncés je pense que
ça veut dire plus y sont reliés aux
autres et plus c'est clair plus on a ces
groupes là qui sont un petit peu à
l'écart du monde des sans abri du convoi
qui a aussi différents taux
d'intégration dans le monde des sans
abri volontaires nous on a même des
individus qui sont totalement
atomisé c'est à dire qu'ils sont
vraiment tout seul et qui sont reliés
qui ont aucun contact avec les autres
vous voyez les liens en fait c'est plus
et foncez pas plus des échanges de liens
l'information ils se parlent mais aussi
peut-être des ressources
et pour en revenir sur sur les revenus
que robert rousseau hier en fait il ya
différentes réalités par exemple sawyer
je pense que c'est quelqu'un qui a des
problèmes psychiques schizophrène ou des
choses comme ça et donc c'est des gens
qui sont à la rue mais parce qu'elle va
devenir plates sont fous ou quoi et donc
ils sont dans la rue parce que ça se
passe pas d'air de nos têtes qui n'ont
pas une approche rationnelle des choses
ceux qui sont dans les groupes sont
plutôt des gens qui ont une approche
rationnelle qui vont vouloir avoir une
vie sociale aussi mais monique par
exemple c'est quelqu'un qui est tout à
fait bien au niveau de la santé montanes
mais par exemple qui va rester isolé
pour se protéger parce que rentrer dans
ces réseaux basse et parfois se faire
dominer aussi et donc on a différentes
stratégies donc la monnaie sur une
démarche plus rationnelle pour monique
puis on a des groupes voilà qui vont
avoir qui vont être beaucoup plus
isolées du squat des groupes beaucoup
plus intégrée et puis on a décaré ici en
fait ce sont des gens qui sont plutôt de
passage parce que dans le monde des sans
abri et a les honneurs sauf qu'il reste
au même endroit qui zone et puis à les
routards c'est ce qu'ils vont voyager
donc ils vont changer de ville et de
choses comme ça on les connaît pas
forcément en tout cas l'auteur lui dans
sa démarche il n'a pas eu l'occasion de
mettre un prénom sur eux sont des
prénoms d'emprunt je pense
voilà ce qu'on nous dit alors après avis
du des individus périphériques et puis à
des individus qui sont au croisement de
certains groupes se sont les binômes
donc c'est super important quand
quelqu'un comme jeff ils en parlent
beaucoup parce que je pense qu'il a
encore des contacts avec lui quelqu'un
comme jeff est relativement centrale
voyez dans l'échiquier il a accès à
beaucoup de gens et ces personnes là où
elle même accès à différents à
différents groupes donc c'est un peu
comme dans la vraie vie voilà c'est du
capital social la façon dont le game
dieu
et plus vous avez de capital social de
plus vous avez de ressources finalement
pour maximiser votre position dans le
champ social
c'est ce qu'on me dit les intermédiaires
sont importants dans la mesure où il y
incarne la mémoire collective du monde
des sans abri parce que pourquoi est ce
qu'ils aient une stabilité de ce monde
des sans-abri avec certaines valeurs qui
restent malgré qu'ils aient du tournoi
et c'est parce qu'on a des gens qui
restent aussi
le lira plus loin
les personnes qui sont les plus
intégrés dans le monde des sans abri
c'est celle qui sont là depuis longtemps
donc et qui sont les plus valorisées
évidemment nous tout est lié à ce niveau
là ce que je disais l'image du schizo
ces personnes totalement isolées et puis
monique qui veut se protéger ce que je
disais
ça j'aurais déjà parlé à pinon
et une certaine homogénéité aussi dans
la construction des groupes alors
structuration morale du monde des sans
abri jusqu'ici on a parlé un petit peu à
tout d'abord de comment il était
structure niveau du temps et de l'espace
comment c'était structuré niveau des
relations troisième temps comment ça se
passe au niveau moral c'est à dire le
bien et le mal qu'est ce que le bien et
le mal dans le monde des sans-abri nous
on pourrait considérer beaucoup de chose
de mal non des sans abri ce soit la
drogue il reconnaît drogues dures la
violence le recours au vol mais dans le
monde des sans-abri peut-être aussi mais
il ya sans doute un certain décalage doc
c'est ici vraiment quelles sont les
valeurs qu'elles sont les systèmes de
pensée qui sont mis en place
ce système de valeurs particulièrement à
travers le respect des valeurs partagées
et l'action de ceux qui se chargent de
les faire respecter
alors ya des règles qui sont ou en tout
cas des valeurs qui sont explicitement
énoncé un souvent on dit les sans abri
disent ah bah ça ça ne se fait pas et
surtout à l'auteur qui lui est nouveau
dans le monde des sans abri donc une
fois qu'il a passé le cap de se faire
accepter eh bien on lui dit non ça tu
peux pas faire
ou alors va valoriser certaines choses
donc pour quelqu'un qui est novice dans
ce monde là bas c'est des messages qui
sont souvent
10 et depuis il a plus vraiment les
cibles et
qu'ensuite il y aussi des valeurs qui
sont respectées mais sans être
verbalisée mais qui sont visibles depuis
la plus les observer d'où la pertinence
de son de son observation
voilà et puis quand ils sont
transgressées ben ça chaque les
personnes et donc lui c'est un profiteur
il prend mais ne donne jamais ça permet
de dire qu'il ya une valeur en relief là
derrière
il dit que lui même il a transgressé
certaines valeurs et donc il s'est fait
il s'est fait reprendre alors on va
vraiment ici ça c'est intéressant je
trouve que c'est très scolaire parce que
tout est détaillé par valeur donc ce
serait
prendre parce que si on fait une
recherche sur les valeurs on peut
utiliser sa et le transposer peut-être à
d'autres milieux tient à ce que les
valeurs des sans abri
sont les mêmes que dans le monde
carcéral par exemple c'est des questions
où je me pose pas ce que je trouve qu'à
des analogies avec la présentation
générale du pack cd r cd hypothèse
devrait en tout cas c'est ce qu'on
pourrait faire
alors première grande valeur c'est la
débrouillardise la débrouille et
systématiquement valoriser et renvoie
aux capacités individuelles de s'en
sortir par soi même le gars qui est
dépendante tout le monde il est vraiment
le dernier des derniers des sans abri
n'est pas du tout valorisé et on va
pouvoir peut-être lui en fait voir de
toutes les couleurs
c'est l'autodétermination l'indépendance
et l'autonomie qui sont alors défendu
parfois jusqu'à justifier le non recours
à l'assistance et ça c'est super
important parce que parfois on se dit
mais sans abri ils ont le droit d'avoir
cei ne profite pas c'est qui ils veulent
leur truc oui mais quelque part c'est
c'est leur valeur suprême il leur reste
quasi rien et donc leur côté de savoir
se débrouiller avec rien c'est un petit
peu ce qui les valorise et donc on peut
pas leur refuser sa journée encore ici
un article sur un peu people sur
mallaury nataf qui est une ancienne
actrice de ce que qu'ils ont la vue et
qui refusait systématiquement oui mais
c'est d'être la dernière des finances de
savoir te débrouiller tout seuls et ne
pas devoir demander quémander tout le
temps aux autres donc voilà pourquoi
c'est important de savoir ça
puisse un recours aussi à la délinquance
se débrouiller c'est parfois délinquance
c'est pour ça que la délinquance pas
forcément dévalorisés dans le monde et
sans abri c'est parce que la délinquance
égale débrouillards dit c'est comme la
débrouillardise est une valeur
importante si pas la première voilà on
préfère délinquants et de brouillard que
pas délinquant est donné dans les clous
et passe de briller
alors l'honneur ben voilà garder son
honneur c'est aussi pas être un déchet
total
c'est resté libre indépendant et l'on
retrouve doug hoffman à ses quelque part
conservé sa phase d'ailleurs c'est un
mot que l'auteur reprend souvent quand
il explique sa son travail c'est
préserver sa phase c'est super important
mais encore une fois voilà quand tu n'as
plus rien
finalement ton individualités c'est ce
qui te reste donc le fait d'être de gué
de garder une certaine hygiène
personnelle
ne pas être totalement alcoolique c'est
super valoriser dans ce monde là c'est à
dire le fait qu'il n'y a pas de
pochtrons absolue dans le monde des sans
abri mais ça veut dire que ce mec là il
sera pas vue comme très positivement par
les autres sans abri que le gars qui
arrive à garder sa dignité bon et
piccoli drogue mais là il a gardé sa
dignité et bien c'est quelqu'un qui sera
plus valorisées dans le monde des
sans-abri d'ailleurs le fameux jeff
notturno parlé ici le dit dans la rue il
ne faut pas baisser les yeux il faut pas
se laisser marcher dessus ni se laisser
aller sinon c'est foutu c'est son
honneur mais jusqu'à sa dignité
personnelle en tant qu'individu
alors la virilité la légalité c'est quoi
c'est une certaine oui c'est les
grivoiseries est fait de parler cru
d'être vulgaire on retrouve finalement
un habitus des classes populaires de
direct voilà ne pas pleurer sur son sort
aussi savoir souffrir voilà c'est
vraiment un habitué des classes
populaires d'ailleurs fait le lien avec
boudu dans sa conférence dans sa
présentation
et bien ça c'est super valoriser aussi
et du coup les stéréotypes super
masculins sont valorisés jusqu'au point
que certaines femmes vous vraiment
vraiment adopté des codes masculins et
vont pas hésiter à se battre pour
justement se faire accepter et être
valorisés dans
une construction identitaire valorisante
donc le fait de savoir se battre c'est
aussi quelque chose de valoriser il faut
aussi être réglo est réglo ben c'est pas
abuser des autres en tout cas dans le
monde des sans abri après la délinquance
ecoroute chose mais je vais voler des
gens c'est que votre chose mais savoir
rendre les services qu'on t'a donné
c'est super important être discret super
important aussi donc on te donne une
combine tu veux pas aller à crier sur
tous les toits et on voit qui est un jeu
finalement il ya des valeurs qui
rentrent en tension ce qu'on l'a dit
tout à l'heure à c'est aussi plus belle
la zone donc il ya des ragots et des
choses comme ça donc tu peux balancer
parfois des choses mais ses intentions
c'est un petit peu comme de notre vie à
nous et il faut pas être dans le monde
et sans abri pour cent soit comme ça
parfois on a des valeurs qui dans
lesquels on est en tension ainsi si on
considère que respecter les règles c'est
super important le conformisme est super
important
et quand même temps d'avoir un ami
proche qui qui fait quelque chose qui
est pas bien est ce qu'on le dénonce
si on a les deux valeurs qui sont très
importants de la côte et le conformisme
de l'autre côté l'amitié ça rentre en
tension
donc il explique qu'au niveau la
discrétion qu'il en a fait les frais lui
même alors que nous indiquions au fret
une combine de rossi pour changer les
tickets restaurants aux pièces de
monnaie dans un commerce précis et ce
dernier nous reprocher d'avoir a dûment
partagé ce plan n'est relativement
discret
dans un certain dans certains contextes
sur ce que font les autres puis le
partage voilà je donne contre don mais
il ya un partage d'abord qui peut se
faire seul et pierre tout pour lui il
sera pas bien vu dans mon sang année
et surtout ça s'est un peu simple
étonnant être un bon maître chien donc
celui qui sait bien regarder son chien
est super valoriser surtout quand on
vient me voilà ça
retrouvez leurs
staffs
des gros chiens dangereux quoi quand tu
sais bien le garder qu il est bien élevé
qui tordent occupe bien qu'il est bien
soigné tu es super bien vu les gens qui
gardent pas bien leur chien ils sont
vraiment aussi un petit peu dans les
commérages
dévaloriser on considère qu'ils sont pas
sont pas très digne de ce côté là c'est
un exemple qui donne c'est ainsi que
julien s'est fait accepter et intégrée
fraîchement arrivé de paris d'abord
après déprécier pardon parce qu'il s'est
approprié un poste de manche et
récupérer la chaîne virulentes d'un sans
abri monté aux stars donc incarcéré
julien s'est montré respectueux envers
la chienne est jugée beau m si bien
qu'il a acquis le droit de la garder et
de conserver son poste deux manches
parce que ces timbres ou maîtres chiens
mais finalement c'est un bon gars il
peut garder ce poste là pour faire la
manche
alors vous aussi kanye archilla sion
internement de la rue l'avait dit avec
dé stigmatiser des gens qui sont admirés
des gens qui sont dominants des gens qui
sont dominés et la domination
l'empreinte en partie des termes de brou
du vélib est repartie elle peut être
physique 1 par la violence a peut être
matériel aussi
mais aussi symboliques et ya un gain
certain le lot ces moments là la dette
la mort dans ce microcosme la 2d sans
abri de nancy et on dit ouais si ça se
passe mal on va appeler le loot salle eu
ses moments les mecs dans le milieu
alors comment tu vas être bien vus puis
tu veux respecter les valeurs du milieu
convient de détails et n'a plus tu sera
considérée dans ce milieu finalement
la ccc une coupe une interprétation que
je fais l'auteur ce qu'ils ont dit mais
finalement peut-être plus tu étais
intégré ben moi tu as envie de sortir du
monde et sans ennuis parce que tu es
quelqu'un dans ce milieu je pense qu'il
le dit mais je ne me souviens plus trop
si le dit aussi c'est moi qui
interprétait ça
ça peut se comprendre nos droits
pourquoi tous
ces corps du social
tout est relatif c'est ce qu'on disait
le parallèlement la dépendance à des
drogues dures ou des médicaments ou à
l'alcool et dévalorisante en ce qu'elles
engendrent des états léthargique peu
compatible avec la position dominante
sans compter sur le fait que la
dépendance physiologique reste une
dépendance et en est par conséquent
dévalorisant les cas mais qu'ils soient
hommes ou femmes font partie des dominés
se font régulièrement exploiter et
dépendent d'ailleurs souvent des deux
minots pour s'approvisionner et donc sa
saucisse sa combat une représentation du
sang abriter le complètement plat
chiffres totalement came
c'est plus compliqué que c'est encore
une fois
alors il nous dit que la violence pas
dans toutes les situations
une sorte de capitale guerrier qu'il
faudra avoir et donc du coup c'est un
lien aussi avec les chiens si tu as un
chien dangereux que tu maîtrises c'est
encore plus mettre de la violence
quelque part pour plus de capital
dernier entre guillemets ah oui fait
aussi référence à des hauteurs marcel
mauss bass ed on est contre dodge a
parlé te donne tu dois rendre un jour
lorsqu'il nous dit c'est que les
structures elles sont pas et si ce qu'on
dit ici c'est que ça pourrait évoluer et
que lui but pour nancy dans le cadre
d'opérations mais l'idée c'est pas que
les valeurs et soit ému mais c'est qu'il
y ait des valeurs qui est intéressant
est donc après une enquête qui pourrait
être intéressante faire le même même
exercice dans une autre ville avec
d'autres contraintes urbanistiques avec
plus de population ou une population
pour voir 15 quelles sont les
différences et là on touche vraiment au
coeur de la démarche des sciences
sociales les sciences sociales sera
jamais d'arriver à des lois universelles
qui permettent de prédire ce qui va se
passer ou comment vont être les choses
non mais on sait qu'il ya des choses qui
se passent et puis à toute une variation
qui est toujours à découvrir finalement
parce qu'il ya toujours une marge de
manoeuvre mais la marge de manoeuvre est
toujours contrainte dans un système de
structures ou dans des systèmes de
pensée
vision du structuralisme mais dans la
vie de reese méthodologique c'est des
schémas penser qu'on va avoir un qui
reste donc c'est ça qui est intéressant
bien sûr social c'est qu'il ya une part
de déterminer une part deux contre un
une part je peux rien d'aléatoire c'est
toujours déterminée comptera quelque
part chez spinoziste
tout était terminé pour moi mais on ne
le saura pas ce que tel point cette aide
est terminée mais voilà donc dans notre
vie à nous d'être humains il ya toujours
une part d'aléatoire allez découvrir si
vous ne trichez 5 est intéressant donc
c'est intéressant franchement si vous
vous lèverez voir c'est quoi une
recherche de sueur sociale misez
l'entièreté du truc obligé de tout lire
les éléments essentiels encore une fois
mais franchement ça c'est super
intéressant
voilà c'est ce qu'on lui dit si ce que
j'étais en train d'expliquer les
structures sociales du monde des
sans-abri reste relativement stable
alors bien sûr qu'elles ne sont pas
immuables bien sûr qu'elles changent
mais il ya des stabilité et c'est ça qui
est intéressant cette structure sociale
demeure informel nous cassons pas écrite
et c'est ça qui me fait dire que bout
j'aime les sciences sociales
elle est tellement belle ni laide mais
voilà c'est rien d'écrit que ça dure
quoi alors comment ça se fait que c'est
nous les vrais mandanda pichot d'une
problématique mais qui est hyper
intéressant et s'institutionnalise dans
aucun texte ni aucune tradition
officialisé mais se cristallisent sous
l'action conjointe des sans abri et
assure néanmoins d'un reproduction d'un
ordre social qui possède une part
d'autonomie là c'est vraiment pour moi
le paragraphe où on résume le coeur du
travail ici et donc d'où vient stabilité
mais c'est par les interactions
finalement et donc c'est pour ça que
nous à pardies new internationalist
voilà et ben voilà on a toute la
bibliographie
et on a fini on a fini ce résumé c'était
un coup dessert je répète c'est la
première fois qu'on faisait ça comme ça
peut-être que j'ai cherché des mots je
sais pas ce que ça va donner
on verra on verra surtout si donner des
commentaires si vous avez aimé vous
mettez les commentaires si vous n'avez
pas aimé ça trop long je modifierai
c'est vraiment un coup d'essai c'est
vraiment un pilote dont j'ai besoin de
nous pour faire évoluer cet exercice et
que ce soit intéressant pour tout le
monde moi en tout cas j'ai trouvé ça
vraiment chouette ça m'oblige aussi à
lire plus des recherches contemporaines
ce que je trouve beau je sais pas si je
les dis aux débuts de l'exposé ce que je
trouve beau avec ce genre de choses
c'est que
montre bien que tout part de la réalité
quoi ici est vraiment une observation
alors la prochaine recherche que je
présenterai j'essaierai de trouver
quelque chose de beaucoup de différents
de plus basé sur une des méthodes
quantitatives parce qu'ils se disent
plutôt sur des méthodes qualitatives
pour vous montrer un petit peu la
différence mais on l'a dit vous bien que
les sciences sociales c'est pas que du
blabla lourd bien sûr oui on va
mobiliser 1000 est un concept comme on
l'a fait ici mais c'est d'abord allés
observer la réalité telle qu'elle est et
si on produit dans la connaissance moi
je trouve ça passionnant en tout cas
merci merci thibault bezazi pour ce
travail
intéressant voilà bah je vous dis à très
bientôt pour une prochaine vidéo de
sciences sociales salut salut